now here's the big thing here's the big
thing everyone wants to know
is it true i am a big fan of fantastic
four you've heard the rumors
that you and john what do you mean don't
make a face
that you and john are going to be reed
richards
and his wife sue in the fantastic four
movie which i think would be a great
idea
no that is fan casting that and no one
has received a phone call that is all
um that's just people saying wouldn't
that be great
and and uh that's it no one has written
in a way
are you too good of an actress to really
participate
are you too good of an actress to really
take that role
seriously in other words maybe that's
why you don't even react to this black
widow thing that you could have been the
black widow in iron man and that could
have been your franchise and blah blah
blah blah blah
because in a way maybe the whole genre
of superhero movies is beneath you it's
not that it's beneath
me it's not it's not that because i love
iron man i wanted to work with robert
downey jr it would have been amazing
but i don't know if superheroes are for
me they're not
um they're not up my alley you don't
like the superheroes or is it that a lot
of women i speak to i think
we're not into comics it's been
exhausted i think it's just that we are
inundated it's not only all the movies
it's the endless
tv shows as well and it's not to say
that i would never want to play one it
would just have to be something
so cool and like a really cool character
and then i'd
be interested but in general i don't
race to see superhero movies and maybe
because i feel
they leave me feeling a bit cold i can't
explain it i'm not
i can't get in there